[Music]
in esports
there's no such thing as being too young
to compete you want to talk about a
young guy
under pressure remember all those months
in the summer haha oh you should have
never kicked cajun b
now this guy's just taking over the
final winning the game for you but on
the other end of the spectrum a player's
shelf life is usually not a long one at
some point
competitors get too old you want to give
it the last chance obviously
um if you cannot then then at some point
you can step down yourself and saying
well i can't do this anymore i really
can't improve myself and all that kind
of stuff so
it's not about stopping at the top it's
more like giving the
last chance you have to be at the top
and if it doesn't work to stop
there are of course the physical
limitations that come with age like
slower reflexes or deteriorating
eyesight
and let's not forget injuries
accumulated during years of grueling
practice and tournament schedules
so you obviously feel that you aren't
playing very well why
i have reasons i i had the hand injury
and i
it's hard to come back for me but for
sure i will do my best in the finals but
yeah if i have reasons to play like i'm
playing but hopefully i will be good
and obviously as the players get older
their priorities are likely to change as
well
i have two kids and a wife who
definitely expects me to
to be a father i i don't dare to to sit
around the computer after practice just
to play for myself
[Music]
my wife would kill me if i did that
whatever the reason may be
most pros accomplish their greatest
feats early on in their careers and
transition into background roles like
coaching or being an igl or they just
retire
but patrick forrest lindbergh isn't like
most pros not only can he keep up with
what the kids are into these days
baby baby baby
justin bieber that pop music that swing
it is sweetie
but this dusty ass 32 year old is still
blowing minds almost
two decades since his career began he's
finished off the frag and our attackers
all that remains and he's only got 24
health dust
this is so doable for us gonna beat
exactly connect
what around vintage stories this guy has
been so good
forever this guy's never played bad i
swear this guy has never had a bad year
in his entire history of cs so how is it
that forest is able to resist his own
biology and compete at the highest level
alongside players who were pretty much
learning how to read when he first
started clicking heads
and how long can he possibly keep it up
look at them all
six nine one of them's gone forest will
finish him off another one delivered
body shots all collected by
for basically as foreign as there's been
competitive counter-strike
there's been forest but if you aren't
familiar with the owner of probably the
greatest beard in esports history
here's a few things you should know he's
a major winning cs go
legend known for his incredible aim
and for having equally impressive
eyebrow control but in spite of
forrest's childish delight at opening
christmas presents he remains a true
boomer
and a stickler for tradition i would
never
ever eat pizza ever again putting his
disgusting pineapple on a pizza with a
would be a disgrace for human humanity
you know
forest is known throughout the community
as a loyal friend and teammate
and as a fierce competitor who doesn't
take himself too seriously
my next question did it
[Laughter]
oh look at that death stare but in
recent years the brain-splattering
rifler has evolved outside of the game
especially with the arrival of his first
child
congratulations on becoming a father
thank you has it changed you as a person
well definitely i'm scared of everything
anyway as likeable as forrest is it's
how he's played counter-strike over the
past two decades that's earned him the
respect
and admiration of his peers i think the
fact that forest has been playing so
long
um aside from the fact of the the level
he's been performing at right there's a
lot of players who have maybe
played towards their like 30s but maybe
not at his level
um is awesome you know i see his
determination and his drive
and who's to tell him that he can't keep
playing
the main challenge he has is okay i have
to stay up to date with the meta changes
with the the updates to the game gun
changes
and if he's willing to do that i don't
see why he can't keep going it's awesome
you see forrest's cs journey began in
the glory days of 1.6
back when the m4a1 wasn't entirely
useless and when he seemed incapable of
growing
any sort of facial hair at all but it
was during those
baby-faced formative years that forest
began to cement himself
as one of the greatest aimers
counter-strike has
ever seen what can robin do that one
ticking away
that grenade was perfect there but robin
will make his frag onto khan it's now
robin
versus forest and forest will come in
gets the head shot i'm not sure if
robin knew exactly where he was but
either even if he did forest was
faster on the trigger in 1.6 and some of
these translates to cs go
he had unreal aim probably the best aim
ever like just in terms of utterly the
peaks he could hit with the same was
unreal
forrest wasn't just a one-game pony
though following his move to nip
which came shortly before the release of
global offensive he proved that he was
more than capable of popping melons
on a new playground already put a smoke
down there as well here comes
it pops down into that ct spawn area now
they push mid at the same time but it's
not going to work out very well
boris picks up a double in the middle
and get right with a third and suddenly
they're planning double going into the
site
isn't going to work out freestyle
absolutely picks off really easily
and then he's picked out himself by
forest if flying goes down to the bomb
side
get right connects on jw and it's going
to be oh
from jumping on down that is the true
ninja style
and forest will finish it off with a
triple kill we might see them
having to really start muscling the way
forward and force is doing just that
kick the first getting the second
oh my god foreign wow
from august of 2012 to april of 2013
nip established themselves as a dominant
force
winning an unprecedented 87 land maps in
a row
and a lot of their early success had to
do with get right and forest's
insatiable appetites for fragging let's
say the first four or five months of
that seven month span
forest was the second best player in the
world and he was had very sick aim he
had one of the sickest names in the game
then you've got get right coming behind
who's so good at clutches this combo
here
won so many games for an ip and they
were just unbeatable pretty much but
over the past eight years
cs go has notoriously revealed itself to
be a game of hot streaks and cold spells
we've seen teams and players burst onto
the scene spectacularly
only to become victims of inconsistency
a few months down the line
and that's what makes forest unique you
see even as nip's trophy hall started to
slow down
and his teammates form was starting to
dip his
penchant for clicking heads never did
it has to be quick from phase they have
no kids before he's in a lovely position
that was sick but he finds the frag on
electro force needs to win that he does
he's almost unstoppable he hasn't even
reloaded he's got six bullets right now
just running in
and looking for the kills he's gonna get
one more headshot taking down
still has not reloaded
stands crouches looks for the shot finds
the first headshot and he gets the
second one as well
forest comes through for nip time and
time again
a lot of people say like best aimers
like history of cs
for me it's forest this guy is literally
the definition of aim
like if you look at like 1.6 frame
movies and stuff like
he's always been good you see that's the
thing in the world of modern
counter-strike
forest is practically a unicorn he's
lived to see contemporary after
contemporary hanging up their mice or
fading into obscurity as fresh young
talent takes over the game
he's one of the very few players that
cut their teeth in the 1.6 scene that
are still playing cs go professionally
let alone dropping jaws on the biggest
stages paris i think that was through
that little jumper at the top yeah he
caught him jumping
so nice shot from forest at least to
pick up one kill oh
he does it again and it's forests
consistency and longevity
not just his aim that the community has
come to recognize and appreciate
but he himself seems equally bemused by
his immunity to the effects of age
this really really weird
i can't put it any different like popski
for example was one or two years old
when i won my first tournament in 2005
and i was
a pro player and he haven't even seen a
computer but now he's sitting next to me
playing
in the same team it's i'm not gonna lie
it's hella weird so how is it that
forest has been able to delay his own
biological clock
while others have decided to let it conk
out
well to find out we reached out yet
again to madison klarkowski our gamer
brain studying expert at the university
of saskatchewan
so there is um some cognitive decline
with age in fact there is a lot of
cognitive decline with age which leads
to increases in reaction time
but the differences between a 30 year
old or 32 year old i think is
forest is 32 and a 20 year old isn't as
extravagant as
a lot of people as a lot of um you know
the esports community might assume
over 10 years 20 to 30 that difference
in online play and tournaments that
difference gets eaten by ping
it's it's pretty trivial they're more
important factors like how many years
you've needed to spend playing the game
for 10 hours a day how much time you
have
dedicated game how carpal tunnely you
are for example how burnt out you are
now while forest's reactions aren't
exactly what they once were
it's likely that the secret to his
consistency isn't physical
but mental you see even if forrest's aim
does
fail him he has a game sense honed by
thousands upon
thousands of hours of experience that
can guide him through virtually
every in-game scenario on top of that
forest remains as focused and dedicated
to counter-strike as he was when he
began
terrorizing his opponents in 1.6 all
those years ago
forest will pick him off brilliant round
for forest and
that motivation makes this old man a
dangerous adversary for any
whippersnappers who might tread lightly
upon his lawn
summer could still catch this cross at
the very least he'd get the information
really early for attacker to help him
retake or he could just get the straight
up kill but if he dies
oh man oh no besides that for now the
prioritization will be towards ramp goes
in bangs through the door
gets the kill on to canadian peeks out
of the hoop as well the second as he
picks up the frag
onto barrapped he just needs to deny the
defuse and waste a little bit of time
a fantastic flurry of frags forests as
he wins the round
we're down to 35 seconds forest making
it jump out behind the smoke as rez goes
down and forest wants to continue he's
now on top of the train
he's going to kick a kill there on henny
finding a second one and taking down que
serado so far a triple opening as far as
turning around it's a quad kill
the takedown arc what a brutal entry
into the bomb side he just won versus
forward them on this side and now
yuri in the back and forest with the ace
to bring down fury
what have an impressive round that is
the equivalent of like
a leonardo da vinci painting that we
just saw everything from forest there
was absolutely beautiful
i mean foresters always be my like idol
they're like all of cs and so my
teammates like say like oh he's not gay
anymore
and i always argue it every time i was
like this guy's
30. he's 30 and still like no aiming
like most people
that's the thing about forest across
multiple iterations of the game and the
better part of 20
years he has been setting a standard in
counter-strike
he's proven that it is possible to have
an enjoyable
long career without hopping from roster
to roster
and he's done so by remaining one of the
greatest fraggers ever to step onto the
server
and that's something we might be lucky
enough to see him do for many more years
to come
so basically age itself and the
cognitive decline associated with it is
less of an impact at 32 than some people
might think
so we might be able to point to it when
forrest is 50 or 60 and not fragging out
quite as hard as he used to
but it's still a little early to shuffle
him off to like bingo
just yet he should still be performing
um assuming that he's
you know able to overcome those other
factors he should still be performing
just as well
there's a lot of situations where people
would say oh
the young guns are going to out aim me
and now react to well a lot of stuff at
a high level
in counter-strike there's a threshold to
where once you're beyond that you could
still
take these duels and win the fights you
need to win it comes down to holding on
to confidence and being able to do
the work the minimum amount of work at
the least that you need to do and
sometimes going beyond
you could totally stay involved at the
end of the day forest isn't just some
terrifying geriatric
capable of humbling counter-strikes a
younger generation
he's an inspiration he's happily showing
them that the lifespans of their careers
can be extended with an
endless passion and commitment to the
game
hopefully the age question has been
deleted
at least that there's no that when
you're 27
that's your time is up it's time to go
that i showed
to people that it is possible as long as
you believe that you can do it
great hold from astralis
it's just a great job isn't it 30
seconds again for a one versus four he's
already got the one kill
tapping away and taking down 25 seconds
he is looking for the straight ace
clutch to try and get back in this game
that would be
a bit of a miracle once again he's
picked up the bomb and he wants to go
upstairs making a bit of noise just
trying to see if he can juke them out
and just be as noisy as possible
maybe they're going to be looking the
wrong way but they're hiding in the the
corners
[Applause]
now it's a one-on-one makers coming in
he's just out of the bond forest
he needs one more kill we'll be in his
story clutch if he could do it grenade
landing on top he's down
to 50.
all right all right
[Applause]
i don't i don't know how to explain why
my headset chord does that like i saw
people were like theorizing they were
like building law in the comments as to
why my headset cable was the way it is
and i'm like i think it's just that i'm
lazy and i spin around in my chair a lot
so i untangled it for this one so i made
sure i've been i've been traumatized by
that this is it's like as straight as an
arrow this time almost